[موسيقى]
شقاق بين وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وفاكنار
يخرج من حاله التلميح الى التصريح ويقول
ان وزير الدفاع الروسي امر بقصف قواتنا
ويتوعد بالانتقام
ليس جل ما قاله الرجل خرج بريكوجي قبل
اتهاماته بساعات قليله بتسجيل مصور حمل
اتهامات للدائره المقربه من الرئيس الروسي
فلادي
وزاره الدفاع ورجال الاعمال
القياده غائبه قاده وزاره الدفاع يقومون
بخداع الرئيس الذي يتلقى تقارير لا تعكس
ما يجري على ارض الواقع هناك روايتان ما
يجري في الميدان وما يتم اعلام الرئيس به
لكن وزاره الدفاع الروسيه سارعت الى نفي
الادعاءات بقصف معسكرات فاجنر ووصفت
الاتهامات بالمنافيه للواقع
ما طفى على السطح من خلاف يعيدنا الى
معركه باخموت وما قبلها التي توصف بانها
المعركه الاطول في الحرب الروسيه المستمره
على اوكرانيا
اتهامات ساقها بريكوجين انذاك بعدم مد
قوته بالذخيره والسلاح ملوحا بالانسحاب من
الجبهه اكثر من مره هناك خاض مقاتلو فاجنر
بحسب زعم بيروجين جل المعارك ليحصد الجيش
الروسي مجدما حققته ربما اخطر ما ورد
اليوم على لسان من يوصف بالرجل المقرب من
بوتين جمله تقول يرحب بكل من يريد
الانضمام الينا لانهاء هذا العار ومواجهه
القياده العسكريه في البلاد